why was it so risky for you to make star
wars origins
and why did you decide to bet on
yourself
oh risky um because i think i'm
on paper well there's a few things to it
firstly
you know when you say fan film right
people there are lots of connotations
about fan films
and not a lot of them are good you know
well you know if you ask for a first hit
of what you think a fan film is
you know they're usually people dressed
up
copying things they've seen from films
usually especially star wars fan films
and this isn't a slight on
other films just saying in general like
fan from general are like
a little bit naff quite low budget a bit
amateurish
you know because and and
uh but what i love about film films is
that they're a playground for people to
learn filmmaking is like to
copy the things i've seen on screen and
figure out how they're made
um so i have a great respect for for for
fan films
but i think why it's risky was you know
uh on paper i'd made hundreds and
hundreds of commercials of direct and
freshening for like 15 years
i've like made five feature films it's
like why is this guy making a fan film
like what what what what like you know
and uh and i know
there was some sniggering i know there's
some people when like
three plus years ago four years ago now
um
people found you know industry
commercials kind of stuff
um we're like what's that guy's gonna
make a fan film what's he gonna do like
dress up in the woods and do a
lightsaber fight like why is he doing
that it's such a
nerd but now though
seeing it people go oh okay i understand
i see i see because it could never have
been that right like and that's why i
had to bet on myself and do something
like risky because
and i don't mean this in a really cocky
way because you might hate the film and
that's fine
um but it couldn't be anything other
than
great right and and that's and that's
hard would say out loud
because it's my work and you can be very
critical of it but i'm very proud of the
film i'm very proud of what we did
what we did um and um
and and it and if it was just a bit math
you know it was just like it's not quite
right like
you're really setting yourself up to
fail by
making firstly a star wars film secondly
a star wars film andy in
indiana jones film and also on the on
the budget that
you know they probably had for catering
for a day like you know there's a lot
that can go wrong
okay but it was betting on the
idea you know he's like when i
wrote that script um
when i was in a place of trying to find
myself as a kind of a filmmaker again
um when i told people the idea
of um i don't know whether they want to
get the spores or not
but um the the the thing that keep the
the core idea of why i was going to make
the film why it is called star wars
origins
people are like i want to see that film
that's really cool idea oh yeah what if
this and oh actually if that happened
does that mean this it just started ask
open all these questions and people
start to be kind of inspired by it
and excited by the idea and it was
something very different
i did not want to make a film that felt
like
it was part of the star wars universe of
this is what happens in between empire
strikes back and return the jedi
and this is that bit of story and we're
going to cast someone that looks a bit
like luke skywalker and cast someone
that looks a little
like no films do that and that's fine
but i i couldn't do that because
professionally
and also in terms of quality it's like
if i was gonna do that i'd need to hire
mark hamill
like you know there'd be no there'd be
no gray area
um so we had to do something different
and also just as a writer filmmaker
um uh if
you know it it's a self-financed you
know production
so it's um it's
me and a producer who
just and i still don't know why but he
you know believes in me as a filmmaker
and believed in the idea and obviously
there's a huge stars fan
and he was like let's do this and
without him i couldn't have
made the film half of what it is without
him
and his support you know and him kind of
really getting stuck in
um and uh and
and that is you know this that's a
commercial company called velvet film
uh who i've worked with for years and
gary cowan the producer
i've known from over many many years and
he's kind of
seen me grow as a filmmaker and a
director um
and from my very early days like 15
years ago so
there's a history there that um
i i i couldn't have made this film 15
years ago like i didn't have
the the capital the weight the
experience the anything to make this
film
you know back then i feel like
everything i've been doing has been
building to making this
this film now you know um
and um and
i think also the reason why i bet on
myself was
the reason the reason why i wrote the
film was because you know i was stuck in
development hell and
and you know or projects weren't
happening or
um you know it's becoming quite
frustrating and and you know and i was
at a
point in my life where i was like oh
maybe i shouldn't be make trying to make
big film maybe i should just stick to
commercials
um and uh and then i realized that
if i was gonna work for free because
basically a lot of
independent film development is you know
then
why not work for free on something i
love and i love stars and i love indiana
jones i love actual adventure i love
lucas and spielberg and and it was and
it's and it was fun
to write something in that world that
you know
eventually i fell in love with um and
suddenly had the bug of like wait is
this the thing i'm missing
you know is this the thing i need
you know if i'm what is going to break
me through that glass ceiling
of you know low budget indie film you
know
is like you know if i can make something
that
is ambitious and
kind of audacious kind of you know
uh crazy um
like who mashes up stars indiana jones
in one film like
it's a stupid idea right like there's a
hundred reasons why that shouldn't work
you know but the fact we sort of found
the gem of why it could work
made it all worth it and without that i
wouldn't have made the film because
you're just making
a fan film because you're a fan of these
films
and actually what i was trying to do is
you know subvert the expectation of what
a fan film is
and and there's a power in that is is
uh i mean i watch so many fan films i
really enjoy them and i love seeing
filmmakers
make amazing stuff with next to nothing
you know and the ambition and the scale
of things and there's some massive fan
films with like
tens of millions of views on youtube and
all this stuff so there's an audience
there's a hunger there you know
for it um but the ones i really like are
the ones that are different like
um one of the very early ones like
george dukes in love
which is you know uh george lucas at
university you know coming up with
the ideas of star wars based on the cat
the people that he's at college with
it's great it's real and it's like a
sweet rom-com basically but it's lovely
um and then you know the classic one
being troops which is like stormtroopers
but cops
again fan films make something that the
studios would
never make you know because that's the
power you have
as a filmmaker you know to do something
different
if you try and do the same you know
that there's a lot of baggage to that
there's a lot that could go
wrong because if your sets aren't
exactly the same and your cat isn't
exactly the same
and you know on the cost you're not
exactly the same then it always just
comes across as a bit amateur
you know which as a professional if
anyone watched the film and thought this
looks amateurish i would have
undone a lot of you know a lot of
um my kind of professional
representation
reputation i think so
but um so risky
but just felt like the right thing to do
it felt like the only thing to do really
felt like the only thing at the time
that
i needed to maybe after being
um so
hurt i can't think of a bad word by
projects not happening and and things
happening
out of my control this is a way of me
getting a little bit control back
you know and and investing in myself
you know um and and my career to go like
look guys
um i know i say i want to be a hollywood
director
you know and i want to make big
commercial ideas well this is what i can
make
on next to nothing you know gives a job
basically um uh and
um that you know
but also i mean that's making it sound
very strategic and
part of it is because it's a lot of
money to spend on a whim
but also it's because i love these films
i love these stories and i love this
style
um and i just loved the sheer
ambition of what we were trying to do
like people say oh write what you know
or
write within your means on the page and
they're like oh if you've got if you've
got access to an empty house then write
haunted phil you know and stuff
like i don't have access to the sahara
desert or a star destroyer
or you know or chase scenes like
everything on that page uh written was
everything cost money like there was no
way of doing it
in your back garden you know um
and uh so i kind of enjoyed
the crazy people excuse me i kind of
enjoyed
the crazy people that got together that
were like i'm with you phil
let's do this you know and uh
and you know and everyone should be very
proud of
you know what they brought into it um
and i guess that's the power of fandom
isn't it it's the power of
um being able to dabble in the
wheelhouse
of like lucasfilm you know because i
know like you know
flipbook studio did all the visual
effects you know
their dream would be
do things in a star wars film so to
do that in this film to that quality is
is scratching that itch for them so
there's a there's a power in that as
fans
um that was very wonderful to see and
embrace
and kind of let loose you know
um and um
yeah so risky yes
but um hopefully
will pay off maybe it's too early to
tell
if you know a film is possibly overly
ambitious or crazy
why do it because that's where the fun
lies
isn't it you know um why make something
that you know you
know how want to make something you know
you know how to make
like it's like you always want to be
growing as a filmmaker
so like being safe
is boring you know and how do you
like i genuinely wrote this film
and the third act of the film having no
clue
how i was going to make it i mean
because obviously i started writing it
for fun like i didn't think i was going
to make it
so i just wrote it because like oh i'd
love to see this in a film this is cool
um and then you're suddenly getting to
the practicality of like oh i actually
have to make that thing
and look anything is possible
with the right team or with with the
right budget right so
you can watch the end of the film and
i'm trying to be smaller light
and see that big big ending and go
yeah you know because like if you had
ilm
or like it's a big studio budget then of
course your imagination can run wild
but the the risky thing is how do you
make that on
hardly anything like that's that's the
crazy thing
give me a huge budget that's easy like
the the hard thing is making things
cheaply and
make them look expensive like that's
where the hard stuff is
that's what made it kind of risky to
make that's what made it
scary in places because you're like oh
this is a big idea and
if it looks a bit naff it's going to
ruin the entire film
it took you three years to make a short
film was it really worth it
100 yeah i mean
yeah and i mean
there are definitely ups and downs in
that three years because the reason why
it took three years was
you know financially took a long time to
you know save the money
and then also um i had kids
like at the start of it that um
you know that delayed things as well uh
i mean there was
and it just seems crazy think about now
a time when we're you know my wife was
pregnant and i was thinking maybe i
should shoot this before
they arrive i'll just pop over to the
desert
and film this thing and it's like what a
stupid idea i'm glad that didn't
that didn't happen um so
um so yeah you know there's a few stop
starts
but the idea just stayed
with me and the more i thought about it
the more i wanted it
and the more um both there's a film that
was out there for people to enjoy
uh like i had this little secret sauce
that partly i was worried that someone
else might come up with it
because i felt like if i could come up
with this concept maybe someone else
can um uh but
uh and the other side just
professionally i was like
just enjoying
being hungry again you know for
something i felt maybe
[Music]
having made so many features and so many
commercials
and not actually having the real
opportunity to make something of this
scale
was like the idea of self-generating
that
you know and disappearing to my office
and like pre-visiting my film and going
well i think the star destroyer would be
here and
oh there's a rocket launcher and oh you
know and they're doing this big chase
and there's sand dunes
like you know it's just a fun thing to
visualize and just to let my mind and
imagination run wild
and um and
the three years i think just made it
better i think
it's uh although this script
didn't massively change from
the first time i wrote it really um
i might have tweaked things here or
there but it kind of the core of it
stay the same i think what what time
allowed was the detail
you know was purely from a practical
perspective and you could probably see
i'm surrounded by props is like took me
a while to acquire
certain special things that appeared in
the film
and they're not they're not things you
just buy off a shelf you know the things
i had to get on ebay and auction and
like all this stuff it's all part of the
fun
as a geek and a collective also as a
filmmaker
um and then just really spending the
time
to previs the film and then study
spielberg you know action sequences and
that classic thing of turn the sound off
and re-watch things and go back and just
tweak something you know give it that
time and it was tweaking but
it's all in that detail i think that
came across and then obviously
i got to shooting it and then crap hit
the fan
and a lot of that prep went out the
window anyway and i had to just
go with the flow um that's just the
um it felt like you know
life imitating our imitating life kind
of thing in terms of like
all the problems george lucas had
shooting in the desert i was thinking
like hang
on i've read all this somewhere
it's happening to me i'm just i'm just
waiting for the big
storm to take my set away which didn't
happen
but uh everything else pretty much did
so
um so yeah uh so yeah the three years is
well worth it because
i and i don't say often but i'm very
proud of the film i kind of
i enjoy it as a fan and i think what i
really enjoy
more than anything else i've made is
that is that immediate connection with
the audience
you know it's like youtube and being
online
you know as i'm having this conversation
my phone is dinging
with comments from people and
that's part frustrating part
part rewarding um because the majority
of people have been very lovely
um and and it's reading comments
uh from people that said like i
saw star wars with my dad in 77
and i watched this film and it kind of
brought back the memories of
like watching the original star wars and
like and that gives me
that now that gives me goosebumps kind
of like wow how do you
like that's like the biggest accolade
you could ever give it
you know to give someone this 20 minutes
you know and move them in that way and
emotionally affect them in that way
and then get and know and have that
immediate connection in that response
through a comment is is very
heartwarming and very makes it all worth
it you know it's kind of like
i'm actually connecting with people
and as filmmakers that's what we want to
do right there's nothing worse than
making a film people go
you know like it's i'd rather people
hate it at least there's a reaction
you know um luckily they don't but
um but it it's it's it's very
lovely to know that fans of all ages
have found something in the film and and
are enjoying all that detail that took
three years to kind of put together
so yeah very well worth it
you